well I am woke now and I can prove it
here you go I love illegal immigrants
yeah Sue me now I sometimes I go down to
do for the day right and I I look out
right I look look for a boat and I see a
dinghy with about 60 of them and I go
over here like right and I pull them in
I pull them in to Shore and I go Women
and Children First they go there are no
women and children just you Lads is it
just come on Lads come on
Lads if I go down there one day and
there's no boat I am absolutely gutted I
don't I just sort of wander into town
and I stand by the traffic lights and I
wait for a big lorry to pull up right
and I look underneath and there's a lad
sort of clutching like that and I go
where you headed he goes Gary liner's
house I go it's just down there what is
happening in the world right now thanks
to the internet where we're able to
share the truth to you enough people are
waking up not only to the BS from the
Hollywood Elite and their constant
lecturing and Haring of you but to the
reality on the ground